hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well within the kong's
mojo he engages his pretty sustained
discussions that have to do with with
time and with place and also with what
we call eternity and ubiquity in
chapters 18 through 24 now he also says
that all these bringing together these
two considerations of time and space
that the arguments pertaining to them
can go off in different directions and
that is what we're trying to do here in
part because it makes it a little bit
easier to follow what's what's going on
through these these court heads up
videos so we're going to look here at
eternity and how that plays out for when
God would be in the monologue Jim I'm
probably going to be able to engage in
some erasure because there's a lot of
discussion going on and we don't want to
miss any of it by trying to breathe it
too much on board but let's start that
with chapter 18 we ran some first brings
up this problem he's already established
that
eternity is one of the divine attributes
and as we saw in the previous core
concept videos
God is not not just in the sense of
having an equality that God is whatever
it is better objected in an unqualified
way to be than not to be according to an
sum so eternity is one of those things
and he says you know from what time has
this so simple nature the creator and
sustainer of all things existed until
what time will they continue to exist or
does he indeed exist not from some time
and until some time but rather without
beginning and without now this is you
know already there well long established
Christian doctrine but remember he
handsome is concerned here not just with
engaging and say apologetics of trainer
you know make sure that that people will
accept that doctrine but he's concerned
with understanding what's actually going
on even exposing whatever sort of
paradoxes or contradictions might arise
and then see if he can resolve them it's
a very bold step on his part so he's
going to argue that because God exists
or is per se that is from himself or
from itself something we've done another
core concept video Hana so if you're
confused about that I go back to that
core counsel video God cannot have a
beginning because that would be contrary
to the very name of the very notion yeah
I mean being per se that is from himself
he says if he has a beginning either he
has it from himself or through himself
or he has it from another earth through
another and you could say well clearly
if God is already agreed to be per se it
can't be that God would then have his or
its beginning from another because that
would make God ontological II dependent
on that other we've already ruled that
out earlier on in the Montello gia box
perhaps that beginning could be purse
or were from itself right so how does he
insult deal with us he says here we go
he kept him a beginning from himself or
through himself although he does exist
from himself and through himself what he
exists from himself and threw himself in
such a way that the essence he is
through himself and from himself is no
way different from the essence through
which and from which he exists so it's
not as if God you know has you can't
separate out parts of God and say well
first this current existent and then
that's the part that you know the rest
of the existence is from God simply is
and there is no beginning to it you know
given this conception what am I having
an end could we imagine that the divine
substance would in some way cease
existing and in some says is more
interesting argument here well if that
were to happen it would either have to
be voluntarily on the part of the divine
substance or everybody has to be
involuntary now if it's involuntary
you're not really dealing with a divine
substance because you know given all of
the attributes that we have already sort
of charted out for the divine substance
to be able to suffer being made to not
exist by something else would be a lack
of power and we've already you know
declared in the previous the government
will go back to the other Court Council
videos dealing with the previous
chapters that God is all-powerful so
it's not as if God could be overcome and
forced not to exist if that happens
that's not even God according to Ansel
as he says in other places
what about voluntarily this raises some
interesting questions could God actually
say well the fun you know the height of
the power is to be able to not exist or
to make oneself not exist
that wouldn't actually make sense
according to an song's conception why
not it's not that as you will do another
place as an sub will point out an
internal inconsistency in that very
logic instead he will talk about other
goods he says here we go he who is
assuredly is the supreme good will that
perish voluntarily why because that by
whose will the supreme will perish this
is not an unqualified good but he is an
unqualified good he is you know what is
best to be in many respects so God is
also the source of of the goodness of
other good things this would be for the
height of goodness to will itself out of
existence for that which made some of
the things good to decide that it would
be fast or better to not exist so Anselm
sees that as absurdity he's also got a
really interesting argument in there
about truth that is going to be
referenced in the day very top day later
on now remember we said that the God not
only as you know you turn into need and
reason and wisdom and all that but that
God is also truth Veritas and in some
makes this interesting argument that he
doesn't follow up on here where he says
is there ever a time when truth doesn't
exist you can't actually decide that in
theatre of that that proposition why not
because if you were to say truth does
not exist
you could ask well is that a true
statement if it is a true statement the
truth does indeed exist at that time
so ant songs way of dealing that with us
is to say truth is actually with a
capital T the truth that all of the
truths participate in and we'll talk
much more about this in the day very top
two videos is it self eternal it
in the beginning or a 10 so you know the
upshot of that is that there isn't
really any anytime when God began or any
time when God will leave walk now in
chapter 20 he is going to I'm skipping
over some discussion about the nothing
involved which is very interesting that
perhaps he'll do another core concept
Vidia about it
chapter 20 he's arguing that God exists
in every time at every place and he's
saying that you know the way we can
think of this is everywhere and always
when I his us he says well God could
exist in three different ways he could
exist nowhere and never right that
doesn't really make sense although he's
going to come back to that very soon he
could exist somewhere and at some time
like for example this book does or or I
do I was born in 1970 I you know you
could say well I existed but this being
conceived and and carried supposed to
report of 69th well but you know in 1968
it did not exist and if said we
identified my life with my body
probably by 2020 70 or any I'll probably
not exist I don't think I'll live to a
hundred created things are bound to
particular times and places and they may
encompass a lot think about a mountain
that encompasses a lot of space and also
encompasses vast amounts of time it is
not completely ubiquitous or eternal
though so somewhere in someplace and
then there's the possibility of the
existing everywhere and in every time so
he says what would seems more absurd
than this that he who exists a freedom
the most truly exists nowhere in never
so it's false that he exists no word
that eliminates one possibility places
further since no good thing exists
without if he's this nowhere and never
every good thing exists no
and never and absolutely everything
exists nowhere it never so that means
that nothing is going to be go ahead and
we have the good of existence so he says
well perhaps he exists determinately
somewhere at some place if that's the
case then we've got a problem
God will only exist in that spot or at
that point in time or interval of time
what does that mean that has
implications not only for the divine but
for everything else because we remember
everything else in an Psalms metaphysics
it is in a multiplicity of ways
dependent upon the divine substance not
only for its being but for its goodness
and for all of the other divine
attributes in which it participates
so the Anselm's argument is essentially
this if God exists in just a restricted
space or it not what we're interested in
here in a interval of time that means
that outside of that God doesn't exist
and nothing in that time participates in
the department that would be a major
problem so he goes on and he says since
this is false right this is pretty
nature cannot exist determinately
somewhere or sometimes and if it said
that through himself he exists
determinately at a certain time but
through his power he exists wherever and
whenever anything exists that is not
true this is another option that people
would probably you know take
metaphysically to say well you know God
exists of a certain time but his power
exceeds him you know that that interval
and it's pervades all time right and
some says no because this power is
nothing other than God it's not as if
God he has a sort of power that is
beyond God God is what God is including
the power that that guy
exercises now in chapter 21 we're going
to get an even more interesting wrinkle
introduced here and sokka's been asking
about God's existence does God exist as
a whole at individual times or does God
exist you know sort of this sliver of
God at this time and if we think about
what we're talking about here it is a
question this God exists in the way that
say human beings exist I am the same
person who I was twenty years ago in
several important ways but in other
important ways I'm not that same person
there is a continuity through time of
the state so I don't want to get too
deep into the metaphysics of time here
and on the theories but there is
generally how it works human beings or
or other things are seen as being sort
of like you know slivers that inhabit
particular moments in the time continuum
going from past into the future you know
with the future things flowing this way
right could God be like that the ants um
is asking does God exist as a whole and
individual times or just as a part so
this like I put here raises all sorts of
problems that we're going to now chart
out this also is going to lead them to
what seems to be a paradoxical
conclusion that God in some way might
exist nowhere and never that would be
there would be a complete contradiction
of saying that God exists everywhere it
always so we need to do a little bit of
a ratio just to get some more stuff on
the board and work our way through this
particular problem if we follow the
argumentation in chapter 21 it's useful
to think in terms of the traditional
timeline distinguishing the three times
that in Western metaphysics probably
most
Eastern metaphysics as well we think in
terms of past a present and the future
like ants some cells we can think of
things in the past as having existent
things in the present has existing in
the present and then future things do
not yet exist but will exist and we can
look at it in terms of things maybe
moving forward into type us with this
arrow we can also see the time itself s
or like sweeping over us so we're
constantly having time roll us into the
future right two different perspectives
on exactly the same phenomenon something
that by the way is a very tricky thing
to wrap your head around now he says we
must investigate whether the supreme
nature exists as a whole in individual
times either all at once or distinctly
at individual times so he asks them how
does something exist as a whole and
individual times all at once if those
those times themselves do not exist now
what does he mean by that
what we're calling the past no longer
strictly speaking exists at least it
doesn't exist in the present by the way
if you're interested in his speculations
about time and eternity you can also
look forward to the day Concordia one of
the last works that Anselm broke but I'm
going to leave that up here
I'm likewise though that you know the
future doesn't exist yet when it does
exist the future will actually be
present and what we're calling present
now will be in the past so how does the
thing that exists at all times exist in
times that don't get or have or don't
any longer exist so Ansem goes on he
says if his life is produced by means of
the flow of times then God has a past
and present and future a lot of those
times he says since his eternity is
nothing other than his essence if as an
eternity had a past present and future
it follows that his essence also has a
past
future now this is going to lead us to
to some some problems and some points
out so that way is thinking about it
must be in some way Mustaine and he says
how can it be that God has no present if
he truly exists but he existed signifies
the past and he will exist signifies the
future so in that case we would have to
say he never existed and never will
exist and this would mean that he does
not exist as a whole at individual times
either distinctly all at once but that
seems to be a problem right because then
we end up with a divine substance that
lady human being is scattered across
something then go against the divine
simplicity wouldn't it we would have a
composite being so he goes on further
and he says he does not in any way exist
everywhere and always either be exist
determinative in some place your time or
exists in no place and time and show me
genetics determinately exist in some
place your time you know some time slice
a long hair where only this time slice
wood would have the fullness of of the
Divine Being so then we're stuck with no
place and in no time that seems to be
very problematic for reasons that we've
already talked about is there any way
out of this through the intellectual
predicament the insult as he will so
often do we'll actually we focus the
problem by pointing out that we've made
it was an assumption that we weren't
really entitled to make that we don't
have sufficient reason to and that is as
will so often be the case we made a big
assumption that we can look at the way
things work for created beings and then
say well it's exactly like that forgot
there is a difference then we have
overlooked here so he says that how can
these two conclusions be reconciled well
perhaps the supreme
nature exists in place or time in such a
way that does not prevent him from
existing as a whole all at once in
individual times or places but not so
that there's several holes located at
different times right he says this law
of place and time seems to constrain
only those things that do not exist
there that do exist in place or time in
such a way that they do not transcend
the expanse of space or the duration of
time but God EDA is one of those things
that does transcend the duration of time
why because God is eternity an eternity
transcends the entirety of space and
time so he goes on and he says that if
we look at these two different ways it
really is the case that God does not
exist everywhere God exists nowhere in a
certain sense because God doesn't exist
anywhere as something that is
constrained or anytime because God
doesn't exist as something that is
constrained to that time you might send
account overflows any sort of time that
you want to put him into if you want to
think of this in terms of containers on
the eye and God does exist in every
place or time and so Ansel was going to
suggest to us that the resolution to
this problem lies in thinking a little
bit more about the nature of eternity
and getting away from the the sloppiness
of our ordinary language and thinking
about this he says if our ordinary way
of speaking per minute it would seem
more appropriate to say that God exists
with a time or place rather than in a
time or place so God doesn't exist at a
particular point in time God exists with
that point of time he has Ansel say you
know pervades get any pervades all time
because all time is
actually here's a very important point
it's not that eternity is simply all the
times rolled up together
eternity is you know a sort of presence
that's more present than the present
that unfolds all the times and that is
what God hits so it's not that God is
present at any point in time by being
there just at that point in time or
interval of time it's rather than that
because God is not even so to speak even
German began his eternity that every
single moment God is with it and here we
start to get to the point of sort of the
limits of our comprehension thinking
about how precisely and that should be
that is something very staggering but
and this is a set of meditations as well
as a set of arguments so it's something
that Ansem thinks is worth us mulling
over and reflecting upon the upshot of
this is he says it's evident how the
supreme essence of all exists always as
well as never that is both in every time
and in no time according to a harmonious
truth understood in different ways